yes torchlight 2 was 2012 and it was
funny because Diablo 3 when it came out
some hardcore Diablo 2 fans and like you
know like people who are deep into
action RPGs were very much like oh what
are they doing they're dumbing it down
and everything and then torchlight 2
comes out and you can pick different
skill trees to go down and you can
customize your character much more than
Diablo so a lot of people were like hey
if you like Diablo 2 you should play
torchlight 2 when it released I mean
like it was cool just because their
classes aren't like necessarily like
your traditional like warrior mage like
hunter or Amazon and it was like a fun
playful thing is more like cartoony like
stylistically and I think that
torchlight 2 from what I remember it was
like an upgrade from one just because
you know you could co-op but now like
you know torchlight frontiers is kind of
like on the horizon and we got to check
that out which is pretty cool there's a
lot they're trying to do with this game
like structurally they're trying to
revamp what an action RPG plays like in
the long term but first I kinda want to
get into the fact that it's called
torchlight frontier it's not called
torchlight 3 there is a reason so being
very reductive imagine an MMO collides
with torchlight 2 or to be more
reductive if you're not really into
torchlight and MMO clashes with Diablo
obviously like it's an action RPG so if
you play path of Exile you know we're
talking about Marvel heroes similar
thing they're taking a lot of
inspiration from pretty much all the
other games but it's called torchlight
frontiers because in the hubs and the
overworld as long as you're not a
private dungeon it's a shared world if
you played destiny and you're in the
tower or wherever the hub is now I'm in
play destiny well you'll run into other
people that are playing you'll be able
to team up with them if you want to to
do this mission or that mission
torchlight frontiers is very much like
that you put a lot mmo's in your time
more than I have
from what we saw obviously we just
played by ourselves do you think that
formula could work pretty well like
running into other people squatting for
this dungeon to go do it yeah I mean
it's cool to have it there I like there
was an a RPG that kind of did that
previously on the name slipping my mind
at the moment but like just being able
to kind of like cue Allah like wow style
with somebody else is like always a good
thing right like I think a RPGs are more
fun once you do have that co-op aspect
just because in theory you're running
into someone else's playing a different
character class but then you know like
they can stand on the front lines if
you're playing a best mage which is like
the wizardry sorcery class and you can
kind of be in the back lines doing your
thing and I always felt like I had more
fun playing co-op so like just having
that as an option is cool just instead
of like hoping that your friends are on
or like you're yeah you're in a clan
that like you can be like hey jump into
my game and it is very much an option
like you can still just play the
traditional let's go co-op we'll see
other people are roaming around the
world but when we go into a dungeon it's
just us in the enemies in the loop
that's another thing they're really
changing to this pose to most action
refugees and Farsight - there's no
character rank it's all your progression
your power your abilities are all based
on your loot and your abilities so like
you can build out certain skill builds
but there's no like you're not gonna be
rank 12 you're not gonna be like like
having paragon levels or anything like
there will be endgame we can get into
that but it's very much about finding
this loot and like getting better just
through the items you're getting yea the
loots interesting and I'll have you kind
of explain it a little bit more but you
know like each frontier is like as you
mentioned almost like its own little you
know campaign or story right and like
there's a gear that's tied to it
so that gear is going to help you
succeed more in that frontier versus
another frontier so we had like the -
for our examples was the hi vid which
was like the insect D frontier right
underground bugs poison like a lot of
poison traps that really mess you up
actually yeah at least when I was
playing
they were like actual hazards they
weren't just something like there wasn't
just flavor it was actually like a
danger yeah and so that gear has more
like you know poison resistance and is
more like I said catered to that area so
like you'll definitely want to wear that
in the hybrid area and vice versa with
like the orc area it's like fire and got
physical the Goblin yes and also art
wise they reflect where you got them so
the bog armor looks like you it's it's
not like Monster Hunter levels of like
oh I killed a monster so but it like
almost like that looks like a bug's
thorax or like a bugs wings like or like
the bugs like gossamer or wedding that
you got and then you know the goblin
forest looks very much like
industrialized pork woodland and stuff
which is really cool because that is how
the progression works and that's what's
weird initially and then we had a lot of
questions about it because like you
mentioned there are individual frontiers
or I guess in a traditional action RPG
if you played a lot of Diablo it's very
much about getting your character to max
level and then doing endgame stuff and
getting like really Opie like legendary
gear which you can then take to other
like maybe like random rolled RNG
dungeons that you want to just get
through quick for the loot and then you
know just really mid maxing your
character
parts of that will exist here but you're
gonna be say you play in the goblin
forest for 20 hours you'll get really
good goblin forest gear when you switch
over to a different frontier it's
essentially like prestiging or something
if you play call of duty
it's like going you're going to another
campaign you're going to the hive it
area and that gear that you got in the
goblin forest is getting scaled down so
you bring your top level goblin gear to
the hive it area it's gonna go down to
like level 4 instead of 30 so that
worried me a little bit at first because
I was like well what was the point in
getting that goblin gear if it's just
gonna get scaled down to like pretty
much useless in the hive it but they are
taking measures to they're essentially
like you are building up really powerful
gear sets but specific to each frontier
so the endgame will be more about
building not just one very powerful
loadout it'll be about building like a
very powerful loadout specifically for
the Goblin area or specifically for the
bug area which sounds cool in theory in
theory like when I first heard it I was
kind of concerned too I mean the good
news is that at least you're not losing
right like you're gonna always have it
it's just that for me even talking to
them I was like well the whole point for
me is to gain power more power and then
just like I wouldn't say face roll
everything but like that makes you fight
in hordes yeah you're just destroying
everything because that's kind of like
where you get to at least traditionally
right and so I think I need to play more
to kind of see how this system really
works I wouldn't put it past them to say
that it's not gonna work because they've
clearly worked on like Diablo 2 and you
know they've got art directors from
Diablo 2 the art director from Diablo 2
if I'm not mistaken they've got like
level designers from Diablo 3 and 2 like
they have and they have a lot of like
they have people from Marvel heroes that
have come over here like they have a lot
of collective talent from this specific
genre and I and I'm really curious see
how they work how it works because they
are essentially trying to revamp like
the long-term progression of an action
RPG which you know is very satisfying in
itself just to get new loot getting the
game character levels get new skills and
build out those characters but to sight
a more popular example like widespread
you've got the Abba 3 you have you know
you have the desert you have fashions
keep you go to hell heaven and hell
there's like these they're individual
area
but you know and you have them you might
have different sets on high levels for
like better resistance but by and large
if you get a really overpowered set you
could Rob ibly use it on in every area
this one seems more like they're taking
those areas and making them their own
discreet single-player campaigns and
then when you go to another one you
still have that gear so when you go back
you have fire resistance for the Calvin
force but also it's you're building up a
new set like a new loan out essentially
a new a new build or you know like
because there are gonna be ways to swap
through them easily but I'm curious if
there will be a point in the endgame
where I'm like I feel like I've really
become powerful and my time was worth it
like getting last year there's
definitely like we dug he said we
haven't seen what 30 looks like right
we've seen like the low level like maybe
up to like the tens and 12 to like that
but given like the rule sets of each
frontier and just kind of like the
modifiers they have on stuff like we did
a phase beast where you know you open up
like a rift
yeah and that rift basically is like
this own little separate dungeon that
had like its own little modifiers like
you know like they have more health or
eggs etc etc right so he was saying to
me when I asked about that weight game
is that like there's the potential now
you know that they could potentially
make a like different frontier that's
just like for endgame that has like all
these different modifiers and then
you're gonna have to find and pick your
kind of like best pieces of like armor
just to kind of like you like with maybe
like I don't know like from what I took
if this could be a vital item is heart
it you could like reroll like dungeon
stats and whatnot so like actually get
the most preferable setup for what you
have I think so but yeah that's that's
just like speculative right that's just
something he said like as an idea yeah
that might not be in the game but it's
just cool to hear that like they're
thinking about that too because you know
they've they're just trying to find a
nice twist on the genre right but still
kind of hold some of those units and I
just need to play it more see like what
does that look like when I beat a
frontier get some of that gear and then
try to like go somewhere else like do I
feel like it was like a painful
experience to like lose that power that
I had well does it feel fresh to kind of
just like be like hey Mike you're in -
I'm gonna join you in - yeah Oh some of
this stuff's not as good but that's okay
because I'm getting all this other stuff
that's high bit you know
interesting to see what happens you know
like I'm it's cool to see that it's
gonna come out on like multi-platform
right it's gonna be a to see Xbox one
ps4 they said they've expressed interest
in the switch but there's no news on it
yeah just like with the Apple 3 come and
switch with like the switches like
third-party iportfolio getting such like
such a high boost it makes sense that it
might eventually I was shocked at like
when Diablo hit console like how well it
played I was pleasantly surprised so
like it makes total sense for torchlight
frontiers also beyond console just
because like the layout works and button
button wise you know and but playing it
was fun like I had a lot of fun and this
and it's all I guess you could see from
the footage right now like it's
pre-alpha footage it's all very like a
work in progress right now like the most
tentative release they're saying it's
just 2019
me and you were guessing maybe fall 2019
maybe a little bit before who knows
there's still a lot that's like in
progress like they're still figuring out
they didn't want to do early access they
said there's like there's benefits to
that development style but they very
much want to like figure this out as
they go and kind of they do have a lot
of ideas that they're just like we're
shopping at the end of every week to see
if it fits and if it does they'll try it
out but it's really interesting to me to
see how they're trying to like take all
their experience from all the other
action RPGs from previous torchlight
games from you know what path of Exile
is still doing and try to make it like a
service because they said very much like
you know like presumably they could
release a new frontier as part of like
their games a service model people go
play that but then you go back to the
goblin forest and you could still play
with your goblin gear and you'll be
powerful and you'll have progression to
do and in theory it sounds like it could
be it could give the game a very long
lifespan it's just like remains to be
seen how they execute it so far I'm
really intrigued as well yeah looking
forward to it as some of the display
torchlight you know one and two like
just to see them kind of come back I was
actually shocked when I saw this
announcement so and having had the
chance to play it I was like yep cool
like this is like a lot of this stuff
like a lot of similarities there a lot
of the fun I had there and kind of just
building upon that yeah just need more
time I think
time will tell yeah
[Music]